وسط فيضان الصور والمقاطع المتداوله من
عمليه الانقاذ وانتشال الضحايا في كم كبير
من القصص المؤلمه اللي الواحد كان يتمنى
لو انها غير صحيحه لكن للاسف حقيقيه مثل
الطفله اللي ولدتها امها تحت الانقاض
والحبل السري فضل موصول بامها وهم
بينقذوها او صوره الاب اللي جالس جنب
الحطام ورافض يترك يد بنته اللي عالقه تحت
الانقاض جثه هامده لكن وسط كل هذه الصور
والمقاطع في الكثير منها غير صحيح وفي
فقرتنا الجيه هذه راح نستعرض معاكم جزء من
هذه الصور والمقاطع خلونا نبدا مشاهدينا
بالفيديو المتداول لشخص بيتجول في انقاض
بيته بينادي على اهله بمقطع مؤلم جدا
[موسيقى]
مع السلامه
مع السلامه يا دار اهلين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وين اهلين لك وينكم يا جيراني
وين العلم
[موسيقى]
البحث اظهر ان الفيديو من اثار قصف روسي
على ريف ادلب من زمان وحتى الصوت مو جزء
من الفيديو وانما مركب عليه تركيب طيب هذه
الصوره كمان اللي راح تشوفوها الان
مشاهدينا تم تداولها وقيل انها لعناصر
الاردنيين بيشاركوا في انقاذ ضحايا في
اللاذقيه في سوريا لكن الحقيقه ان الصوره
تعود اغسطس الماضي هي من عمليه انقاذ شابه
عشرينيه وقعت من مرتفع صخري في منطقه
البحر الميت في كمان صوره الكلب اللي
بجانب يد تحت الانقراض طلعت كمان
معروف بالضبط تاريخها يعود لمتى لكنه
موجوده على موقع
الشهير للصور سوره الطفل هذه برضو اتضح
انها مو من تركيا ولا من سوريا وانما
مصورها اوكراني وموجوده ايضا على عدد او
مواقع عديده للصور والان متداوله على انها
جديده ونفس الشيء ينطبق على صوره المسن
هذا اللي خلفه وشاي الخبز وبرضو لقوها على
مواقع عديده للصور وحقيقه انها من تركيا
وانما من زلزال سنه 99 واللي كان مدمر هذه
الصور كمان لمنزل مدمر طلعت مو صحيحه
والحقيقه انها من تركيا فعليا ولاثار
زلزال فعلا شرق البلاد لكنها من سنه 2020
ولا علاقه لها بالزلزال المدمر الاخير
[موسيقى]